er soll seinen todkranken vermieter
aloys es um 83.500 euro betrogen haben
die staatsanwaltschaft klagt an der
rentner der an einer krebserkrankung
gestorben ist vertraute dem angeklagten
und überschrieb ihm seine vorsorge und
die kontovollmacht der polizist markus h
behauptet dass er für 300 euro im monat
den rentner zur chemo ins krankenhaus
begleitet hat seine dienstzeit auf 50
prozent reduziert und für den
medikamente in der apotheke besorgte er
hätte sich auch um die überweisung des
geldes an alois philippinische ehefrau
kümmern sollen die fahnder entdeckten
nach der anzeige des rentners in einem
bankschließfach des polizisten 52.000
euro
der angeklagte bestreitet aber das geld
von alois bekommen zu haben
der verstorbene sagte noch vor seinem
tod der polizist und er sind nie freunde
gewesen niemals habe er geld von seinem
freund alois verlangt im gegenteil er
habe sich für ihn aufgeopfert ihn zu der
chemotherapie gefahren wo sonst keiner
da war und habe sogar seine dienstzeit
um 50 prozent verringert
hallo ich habe ihm das geld gegeben
damit er es nach und nach an seine
philippinische ehefrau auszahlt damit er
medikamente besorgt und fürs haus da es
lediglich 300 euro habe er monat für
hausmeistertätigkeiten bekommen
letztlich wurden aber bei einer
durchsuchung in einem bankschließfach
des polizisten 52.000 euro gefunden und
nur ein bruchteil des geldes war
tatsächlich bei der ehefrau angekommen
sehr grotesk wurde es in diesem prozess
auch als die anschaffung eines e
scooters und eines einer playstation
thematisiert wurden die ganz sicher
nicht für den rentner gedacht waren
schwer belastet wurde der polizist zudem
von einem bankkaufmann der dem rentner
im sommer 2017 30.000 euro in bar vorbei
brachte die der polizistin an sich nahm
und kurz darauf selbst eine bankkarte
für das konto des rentners beantragte
daraufhin wurde der rentner misstrauisch
zeigte den polizisten an
wenn der beamte verurteilt werden sollte
zu mehr als zwölf monaten haft auf
bewährung dann wäre er seien beim
kostenlos ein urteil wird für den 18
november erwartet mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bild schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren